I understand you were expecting your
second child is that's right yep
is it a do you know if it's a boy or a
girl well we don't like to gender split
we're gonna go with boy gender a sign
boy okay have you come up with any names
yet that's the big pressure it's a lot
of pressure we're considering Carl's jr.
and we're also considering Ruth's Chris
Carl's jr. Ruth's Chris cuz I did some
research like ruth's chris is a great
steakhouse I've always but I've never
understood that name Ruth's Chris
Steakhouse you shouldn't understand that
name because what happened was a lady
named Ruth bought a place named Chris
Steakhouse and she wanted people to know
it was hers so she called it Ruth's
Chris which is so dumb yeah but if I
have a son he's mine he's Tom's right so
I could go with Tom's Ruth's Chris
Steakhouse Segura and I think I will
you're gonna do that I don't know I this
I see no reason not to call a child that
eccentric do you I mean first of all I
understand you've got a special gift for
your first son is that right that's
right yeah I mean you know on Instagram
it's a great showcase for artists and I
follow a bunch of artists and I found
this one that I loved this guy named
baleen from Spain and I started
following him and I was like I'm my son
I you know I could maybe I could
commissioned artwork from this guy of my
son that's cool so I contact them again
in touch with his assistant and all the
conversations are in Spanish like I
speak pretty good Spanish so I'm like
feeling myself I'm like I got this you
know and we're discussing the price and
how long it'll take and then they send
the dimensions and it's metric and I
don't even think to calculate that I
just go like well I've decided that all
paintings are three feet by two feet so
that's what this will be too
and then it arrives and I take it to a
frame shop and I don't need to do I
don't even open it and I just take it
straight there and I tell the lady I
want this framed and I just I take a
walk around the shop and I hear her
audibly gasped like she's a she goes sir
you might want to see this and I go what
and I go oh it's seven feet tall we have
it take a look at this but take a look
at this if you had no idea I had no idea
it looks like you're entering the King's
lair when you walk down the hall it's
like I like like my son is like I have
to be on the entire wall when we end
there and people walk at my house boy
this is intense dude like you know you
see your son runs this place yeah sure
now here's the question what do you do
for the next kid because think about
that of course and now my wife she's
like you know like you can't do like a
small painting I'm like what how about
we will do a gold statue maybe a
fountain with some fish and people can
bow when they enter yeah yeah and we
have these two little psychos running
around the house yeah these two little
King Joffrey's running around why aren't
our names on the front of the house yeah
I'll be like oh that's the next move all
right it's your house
you